ci pensa di fermare se lo è ma cos'è ho
capito bosso salve persone che guardate
i miei video sono contento di perché ti
apri a metà barca è giocare e creare
aggiornamenti impostazioni crede
smettere smettere belle attenti ragazzi
che vivete questo nuovo video sono fa
rigenerati saltati sul gas line glory
gioco della brace di comunità un'altra
ufficiali dalla giunta
voglio provare ragazzi a fare altri
livelli se riesco tipo canturio mouse
if you can torna a casa se riesci
bongiorno e tini allora proviamoci
perché ancora non non ho provato tutti i
livelli visto gioco visto che hanno
aggiunto un sacco di livelli visto che
c'è la possibilità di crearli gli utenti
di questo splendido gioco hanno pensato
bene di rompermi le palle
esatto fuga chiave perché hanno tradotto
in italiano se non sanno l'italiano
posso passare di qua perfetto perfetto
tanta roba dirlo prima che mi sta
sparando là dietro infaber il fame cava
cà cianci venduti a jean seberg cucinano
la metanfetamina attenzione attenzione
perfetto perfetto porchia manca lo sto
facendo rialza di cognola innalzati
pagani ci crea me a posto era svenuto un
5 minuti era l'effetto dell'alcol e
della sera prima e mi fate korca eva non
ci posso credere non ci vogliono tre
grande successo
craxi è però affatto a vincere è
possibile
curri curri culum segnala un errore noi
e segnalo italiano the strange world
facciamo questo non mi sembrava carino
pronto partire grazie partire ragazzi
partire a una ce n'era
s beccavo quella ma come oggi scrivo ho
ragazzi quando giocavo con ste
ho appena finito di dirlo stavo per dire
quando giocavo con stretti facevo cagare
perché adesso riesco
niente stavo scherzando ami fare parte
di qua che culo ma sarai stronzo stata
una parte a caso parte quando passò
parte a casa un progetto per farli solo
un idiota porca eva e non c'è verso per
mi fai fare fermi fermi fermi fermi ok
ed è partito mio figlio a caso
[Musica]
chrome e questo succede e vabbè ok posso
sentire l'agopuntura vista difficile
ragazze non si aspettava personalmente
posso cambiare la visuale che non vedono
ecco adesso sì che vedo dicevo posso
vedere di sotto che non ve dove sto
andando grazie è impossibile non posso
non puoi andare piano service chiama dal
piano ce la faccio no no no ok per me
piano però nella nera difficile giro dai
traguardo traguardo signori non si è
fatto troppo male secondo me fa meno
male della friends on questa cosa va bè
ragazzi curriculum abbiamo la pista
nella sua montagna dell'agonia nov
hazard land a jabla strano che faccio
più facilmente queste che quelle ormai
facciamo degli young fendi partire dai
vai partire partire come si è usato ok
ho capito la madonna
tesoro ti sei fatta male volta dove sta
guidando quest'uomo magari non ha la
patente ma sono quasi sicuro che non si
quindi così ok deve domandare questo
traguardo dove andare prima c'è posto
giusto è scemo questo è tutto drogato
che sta succedendo
non voglio andare al traguardo per una
volta non ci voglio andare nomi ci
mandate ecco i profili più presto
macchina tutto a posto lo ha posto la
ragazzi ce la possiamo fare la young
family può fare questo livello meno
sento fermi tutti perché salti così per
la madonna fermi media di spararmi
vorrei evitare la rampa se tanto quando
la prendo muoio ma non riesco a evitarla
neanche volendo quindi niente perchè
devo secondo verone volto fi piano piano
piano no ok ma se si sopravvissuto 800
cannoni prima come mai morì adesso per
niente allora degli anni femminile una
sega facciamo gianetti minimo ragazzi io
confido in voi perché niente fanno
cagare gli altri e verso certo punto
proviamo con lui non capito credo di
poterci disco non lo so è perfetto
bravissimo non così non li va bene sei
comodo perfetto non sei più comodo va
bene va bene mai di omaggi o falsa
no no così non mi fare qui mi è piaciuto
il ralenti è stato fantastico
[Musica]
e ci rimarrò finché non muoio visto a
livello so io la sento
ma perché allora il primo giro l'avevo
fatto bene come che non riesco più a
farlo spiega mi spiega ok occhio di una
palla cer
[Musica]
allora gesù ci benedica tutti grazie
grazie
tua madre andiamo per se c'era un altro
no giusto chi c'era di altro
earl bella è bella e la gamberone eccolo
lì perfetto mica facilissimo palermo dai
mezzi non ti fermare a divorarci meta di
chiamare sei un libro è ma cos'è ho
capito bossi però e 130 gli associamo
arrivare a 130 lo sa questo carretto
stupido
no no 130 non è la giusta velocità però
tutto questo cosa è meritata allora no
no no no no
sì sì sì sì sì bellissimo occhio bravo
no girati porca era mai tritto su una
macchina 6 non è che sei ok perfetto
perfetto non mi devi deviare la strada
si sta un annuncio perfetto non mi
appresto c'è point e stupido
beh
[Musica]
oddio oddio oddio oddio fermi veloce
leva 180 anni per fare suo livello tutto
distrutto me ne frega un ca maestoso
grazie grazie ragazzi è stato è assurdo
non ci posso più fare non lo tocco più
sto gioco è stato arrivi la prossima
domenica sempre grazie glory non vi
preoccupate quindi regazzoli spero che
vi sia piaciuto un nuovo episodio dopo
questo bordello di roba che alla fine
comunque società far mentre che è di
tutto rispetto l'ultima volta games in
un episodio hanno fatto uno quindi va
bene spero che avete vi sia piaciuto
cose traduce il momento è un bel live
per l'ultimo livello meritano 50.000
lagann nero almeno almeno quello ragazzi
siete messi diventa in circa ma cos'ha
visto e non so prendere i telecomandi
perché io faccio quindi non riesco a
chiudere i video porca eva bella ragazza
[Musica]